do you feel like uh you you feel like
you got like something to prove with
this project yeah
i got a lot to prove i i just really
well really
it ain't even a lot it's just basically
i just feel like a lot of stuff that
goes over here because i rap too fast so
i have to slow it down and i actually
haven't wrote a song since
rover so
i i started back writing and getting
back to the old like everything taking
my time your old format yeah so let's be
clear when you say you haven't wrote a
song since rover you mean like writing
it down in your phone or
before you would just freestyle punch in
yeah punch in freestyle yeah do you feel
like writing because you know nowadays
everyone punches in and i think there's
a gift in a curse with it like you said
because you don't really take your time
i feel like it's lazy i just feel like
because at first i always that's how i
came up i'll be right so i feel like if
you came up off of
writing and you then you go back free
you go to freestyle and you changing on
your whole
like
ground-up game like you came from the
ground up right
you sitting up here doing some stuff
that that ain't help you ain't come on
like this so why you doing this it's
like a [ __ ] a [ __ ] going
being a comedian then just jump to being
a rapper
it's like you ain't go up doing this you
got to stay doing this because that's
what all your fans want you to do yeah
no that's real so this is kind of like
you're back this whole album you were
writing
it's kind of like you know i guess then
the title of the album says it all right
yeah for sure just back to the [ __ ] that
got you here